all right so now it's just a matter of
how many get eaten by this right oh no
okay when will we learn
what was that noise
hey everyone it's random encounter
there's Waters if not Daniel Dwyer this
is Mary Kish she's not Daniel Dwyer
either no we're filling in because he's
vacationing the wide world of San
Francisco he's riding bikes I have no
idea what he's doing I don't know what
he does when he's not here he's a
mystery an enigma
so we're gonna be playing a game that we
have never played before mousecraft it's
called mousecraft it's by a development
studio called crunching koalas crunchy
koala Mary's semi-literate we're going
to be dealing with that throughout the
stream and uh let's just do let's just
go ahead and do it there's different
types of intelligence there's reading
sure that's one of the types there's
watching videos to understand the story
you think you're so fancy of mousecraft
so we're gonna have to get our mad
scientist on a little bit okay
this is a cat scientist named
Schrodinger that's in reference to a
science thing working on a very cheese
consuming experiment he worked very hard
on his project but he failed repeatedly
until he ran out of cheese oh no then
what
with only one choice
speed up the game by holding Square I
don't understand okay look all right
cool all right so it looks like we've
got some plans some scientist plans
going on here and we gotta start
on work we're gonna work on section one
our large Journey Schrodinger of mouse
murder will begin
oh
busted into his piggy bank
spend all his savings you didn't save
very much and buy some cheese
so we could go through the experiment a
few more times
oh I see hmm
help the cat in his experiment by
Leading that is a terrible TV voice at
least one Mouse oh my goodness
you're not even trying
start with
Square now we're talking
mice can jump but only one block High uh
so cool I've said that a few times
like brick with square
put it on Boom good job
so this is like a little Lemmings action
I heard it's kind of like Tetris meets
Lemmings go go mousy cheese eaters
Tetris why is it Tetris because you get
Tetris blocks I guess that was a square
technically
do you know they're called there's a
technical term for those
for squares no for Tetris blocks
so I was always told that the technical
term is square it's Square yeah what's
the technical term for that one the L
they're all tetraminos
yeah that's the that's the type of thing
they are
so they give you the blocks in advance
and you gotta figure it out boom go go
Mouse go
you just hold square and let it run its
course oh this is easy man Gruff on all
this cheese
scarfing that cheese
with how good you are
a rotate bricks L1 and R1 we're getting
a little bit more advanced now some
Advanced Techniques
um rotation
oh come on get there
okay oh can you do this weird move yeah
I'd like to see them die you'd like to
see the mouse die okay
I can't let the mouse free
can I how do I move the thing once I've
put it down
okay wait yeah I can what is it it's
it's a circle circle it's a backwards
button you know it's amazing for the
simple experiments that he's able to go
back in time there we go this is what
happens when they die oh a little ghosts
come out of us he fainted that's because
he spent his last money on this cheese
that's a really good faint that was
impressive like faint noise yeah good
job
oh what's your good evil scientist laugh
what's your best like this should this
cat or just like in general like yours
you're like
evil laugh
I think it's got to come from like below
like deeper in diaphragm so it's like
one of these guys you gotta sort of get
to get good posture going and that is
like that it was like a pretty good face
in there too yeah well you gotta it's a
it's a full body evil kind of thing
what about you what do you got well I
feel like I can't go as deep as you yeah
you got to play to your strengths
um but I would do more of like a witch
cackle you know like if I had tricked
someone into
my candy house
and then I was boiling them alive that's
I mean that's analogous to what a mad
scientist does basically yeah it would
be like
okay go up in the end like that like but
then you come back down not here
yeah you gotta come it's like a little
ending Crescendo all right you get these
blue things
cool all right what's uh so I feel like
the game has now begun
what's on the on the back of the evil
scientist he's got like a fan on the
back of his
like little jet packs
all right so what you've done what
you've done you like that move
so I'm trying to get these mice to get
these shards
do mice do mice perish if they fall I
think that they will die like two let's
see
oh wait no they're not even gonna make
it how do you oh yeah no I didn't
what if you rotate that first block
I don't know if I've thought this
through
that's good
how will they get the other one they'll
just die they'll Miss A Shard
back to well you know what let's find
out if they die first yeah I'd like to
see this
how far can a mouse fall before it dies
not that far
now we've learned
let's go back let's go back let's go
back to the beginning okay
how are you gonna get that really
tall shard
is it not I think I think that's where
the puzzle begins it's figuring out
how we get that tall Shard because I
could do this and this is going to
complete but I'm not going to get that
last shard
you know what I'm saying I know what do
you know what it is that I'm saying what
you're throwing all right down let's
I feel like go on we gotta manage
these are gonna fall right if I put it
here it falls down yes
is not beneficial
well this piece the first piece has to
go either there or up here
I feel like this is a good play for that
piece it does seem like but then you're
dropping from that really tall one
down
how far can they fall
like do we know how far they can fall
that's what experiments okay are all
about that's true let's let's try this
let's can they fall two squares I mean
at the end of the day go Mouse go they
can they can fall too great they might
even be able to fall three
maybe we'll reveal that in further
experimentation to you sir a hypothesis
yes that the mice can survive three
blocks why would I release oh
release the mouse first now there's
timing involved
oh Mouse go go Mouse go so obviously
this is us learning the basics
yep
I feel like you're I'm controlling here
we're playing this on a PlayStation 4.
this game is available for 14.99 on a
PlayStation 4.
you can also get it on Steam on Steam
um we saw it on PC but I wanted to play
it on PS4
because there's not that many
next well current gen games to be honest
with you so I wanted to see if this is
worth getting for the PS4
I wanted to play a PS4 on the old live
live stream yeah all right we need to
get those mice the opportunity to do it
I wonder if you can
put down wait hold on you have to be
able to put down blocks for them to turn
around correct or will they jump off the
ledge and kill themselves can I pick
them up once I put them down like mid oh
I think once they're down they're down
another hypothesis
um yeah
so I think you
or maybe they'll just turn around maybe
they won't commit my Suicide why can't I
let the mice go go Mouse go
I have to okay you can't be holding a
piece in the environment when the mouse
so I want them to once he does that I
think he'll turn around oh what
active pause has been turned on what the
hell is that
you can use it to freeze time I think
you held a handy television calmly place
the bricks
calmly calmly everybody remain calm
relax freeze time
just all right so that's the edge that's
kind of weird that's like the edge of
the level yes all right well we're gonna
have to oh we're starting over all right
we have to go back yeah because I didn't
know that was the edge of the level
we did this experiment without full
knowledge
so what I need to do first we're going
to try to wait where am I where's my
thing oh the mouse are going
where's my
mouses are going again where's my
controller
oh God that was weird
all right mice can we just can we just
go back inside mice thank you thank you
China said I need you to calmly
I'm gonna have to put that down once
afterwards the mice
so
go mice go
I'm gonna use the active pause no I'm
not I'm not gonna use it no no
you're out of controls yeah people have
been saying for years
that you've gone crazy that you had gone
mad
and I defended you
you don't understand Mary he's gone you
just don't know me he's gone man my word
when it is completed will it be such a
Wonder on to this world what okay so
they can fall three but they can't fall
four I knew it
my hypothesis it was correct
congratulations Dr Mary
you're sure to be published now thank
you all right my death was my minor
in college
death yes
I have a friend whose job is do
something
ah
so glad you calmly placed that ball oh
yeah no active pause for me
So Good Feet of my mouse pants I don't
know all right let's talk about Mouse
pants on
you didn't know this about me you guys
knew this
yeah I have Mouse pants I wear them
underneath my normal pants because
people don't understand what mouse pants
are and why any grown man would want to
wear them but they're they're pretty
good are they made out of dead mice I
mean they're not not made out of this
make a mouse pant out of all right well
they touch that blue Shard if they fall
into it yeah totally but they need to
not die I mean
so I don't see why that's my concern I
have to break their fall
and this one looks like I'm going to
want to use it to go there so let's just
put this thing down here
go mice go
Intrepid little Mouseketeers
robotically moving I mean the stressful
part about this game
is that
unlike Lemmings which I find to be
soulless creatures
I don't like to see these mice
die you like the mice more than you like
the Lemmings the Lemmings to me didn't
have a lot of peel I never really
worried or got upset when the mice or
when the Lemmings kick the bucket do you
remember the noise that the Lemmings
used to make when you made them commit
suicide because you actually needed to
do that in the lemmings certain
um puzzles required you to have them
commit suicide there's a really dark
thing for a game and I think about it
and they would make you do stuff like
when you tagged them they would grab
their heads and they would go
and then they would shake and they would
implode whoa
um wow they wouldn't be killed by
environmental column I have only the
Vegas remembrance of lemmings they
wouldn't be killed by environmental
mental Calamity they would like
spontaneously combust they
I assume forced themselves
to explode internally okay
um
from your will you were like the God and
if you commanded them to explode they
would grab their heads and go
wow and they made this really cute after
the actual
horrific act they exploded with a simple
and then they just these little lemming
dust
floated in the air disappeared
and
that was the end of them and then nobody
ever discussed it ever again wait that
bomb was worth two bombs but the other
one was worth one they're random bombs
I'm really confused can you so you can
destroy bricks that you have been
putting up no I can destroy any of the
tetraminos in the environment okay I
have to destroy this one
I'm gonna have to destroy this one right
so I'm not going to get that other thing
so I don't have enough bands oh you're
out no I probably did not all right
let's retry this one all right
nothing less than Perfection too many
bands so I got a bam I gotta the bam
that guy
and now I don't have an e button so I
need to let them let the mice be free
okay
now I got one from there okay
so all right now I need to I want to
blow this that's a good idea
hold on a second let me active pause bam
calmly let us discuss in scientific
terms I should destroy our options
this one uh-huh yeah see oh wait nope
nope okay I feel like you're not doing
this calmly no I'm not gonna kill this
freak it out I'm not gonna kill it don't
worry good oh God
that was stressful wasn't it I'm
stressed out that Mouse is over the line
its nose is over the line is it gonna
die it's not gonna die
it died it full on died and that was
super dead mouse dead mouse horrible
Mouse murder Mary is distraught do it
all right I think
I think it's okay all right so now I
gotta let them collect these this bomb
that's a good choice and then you will
explode the line
which I suppose will make that fall good
yeah and then you should have another
bomb the bombs don't actually harm the
mice
again he can also go back in time
uh all in the name of cheese here all in
the name of cheese all hail cheese
and cheese We Trust
all right uh I'm gonna have to do
something to turn those mice around
also something to get the mice up to
this other bomb so
let's see
that
this would turn the mice around because
if they just start right they're just
going to cruise right on by that dude
that's right and you will miss your
initial we'll come back around to get
this thing right so they'll get the blue
guy
but then they're just going to go back
and forth here and it's going to be
useless
so let's try the block
and then we'll uh
unleash the mice okay they'll get
stopped by the level they'll get a bomb
then you destroy that
didn't have much of a purpose I feel
like it didn't go very far in life
yeah well you know not every
every bomb is meant to succeed them to
go up
and then now that they go down you can
destroy this line blocks they can get
the other blue guy
wait
no all right are you out of bombs yeah
okay now no it's getting interesting
all right well the other bomb situation
is up here okay but that's only one bomb
and that one bomb like here this this is
gonna complete the puzzle
right because you won't you can how do
you know if a bomb's worth one bomb or
two bombs I was mistaken about the
earlier bomb I believe it was you lied
to me well it's I mean lying is like a
deliberate deception like I know
something else to be true you ignorantly
lied to me in my ignorance I gave you
incorrect information
yes so let's just take that L Word
Science can't work under these
conditions all right
let us hold on there's one of these
things now he's introduced a ratoid
do not let your mice get close to them
the result of schroding is not a very
successful experiment where he tried to
create an attack a mechanical advice
Schrodinger you son of them luckily with
my experience in rats
should be able to manipulate them
being the rad queen of course
um
all right I have a thought
let's hear it
if you let them go they'll go down and
hit that blue guy bottom left yeah
how's this one here yeah so you could do
that
and then I'm out of ideas cool terrible
work
um but if they go and get that guy too
so you have to do they they don't have
to be in order by any means
we should discuss okay yeah so like how
about this
first up
here what if I have them get the bottom
two first right so here's the reality I
can't do that because I don't have a
bomb I need to get that bomb in order to
do anything the reality is you get two
bombs in the level right two bombs and
you already have the two things that you
need to destroy so anything you put down
you can't destroy if I want to get the
maximum which we do because we're yes
because we're a perfectionists at this
stage we'll probably give up and uh not
be that way sometime soon
but for now for now
um what I'm saying is is any block you
put down you can't destroy
so we need to consider that
while we
um
place blocks
so I think that one of the
if we put a block down now
we won't have to destroy that will allow
them to get to that cheese
you don't have to destroy it but it also
has to enable them
right to get
back
if I here I think oh you have to um I
need that bomb to blow that thing up
hmm
don't have chat with me
get the where did that chat computer go
damn it Benito
all right so
in order to get that so like if you put
sorry you wanna do you want to grab the
controller I stood up
she stood up in your head disappeared
Mary it's very disconcerting for the
viewers you must understand this is an
experiment I feel like the key might be
I lose my head like that'll fall do
something where it'll fall right yeah I
think that seems reasonable if you put
the block
above that it would fall so that you
could still use it once you blow that up
but would that benefit anything this
block is here blocks off the two bottom
ones and there's no way to come back
from that right so I think that working
backwards if we blow up this bottom one
which is required in order to get that
gem that whatever those things are
called uh we have to Magic
we blow that up
then that will fall into place but when
how will the mice get in there
once we blow it up because that'll fall
right okay I think I have an idea go on
we're gonna set these guys loose okay
right so they're gonna do they're gonna
run they're gonna grab that one below
and then I'm gonna have them go back up
there now yep and then you pause it so
that you can calmly place a block yes
calmly
calm down all right well this is still
not gonna really help because
this will allow them but then I can't
but then they won't get that other blue
guy yeah because I could put this down
right
nope nope
there we go let's think this through I
think we're on to something here I think
you're on to something here so then they
go like this
so now I have this bomb
so now I can blow this up and they can
continue right
but then there's no way for them to get
below or above
you've lost your steps
well I can probably build steps with
with this
yeah I could build steps with the square
like I could do
okay
I trust you I could build steps like
that right right
we'd have the same result we had before
we gather the last bomb and we have to
destroy that last piece and we have to
destroy this last piece
and you always have to destroy that last
piece so that you can get the cheese
kill mice you killed the mouse I don't
know it said kill mice I chose kill I
wanted to choose restart but instead I
chose kill mice beware of enemies
couldn't
all right
aren't good enough
Mouse murder schemes
I feel like that's just the way of the
world I think you're onto something here
that they would go down get this blue
come back up and then we're supposed to
change the scene
I believe you're correct here okay okay
let's pause it actually no here how
about this no
do you want to pause it
pause with these guys
okay because I like the idea of having a
bit like
this because now I can I still can't
blow that thing up
but
people can't climb two no
so they can't really do anything down
there
without the bomb it's a bomb
I say that all the time
I need a bomb
if only I had a bomb
most of my issues I really just would be
resolved a bomb like just one not even a
lot I'm not asking for much
a measly bomb single bomb would do it so
if you put the square
it's a square the square when they were
up if you put the square there
like so the mice would have to live
right yeah and you put the square there
then they'll get the bomb
and then you
have to I don't know how they'll get I
don't know how they'll survive yeah and
then there yeah see you then
you can only blow up one I can blow that
up but then they're stranded in that
hole
sure
so maybe
what I do is
if it was the end one in the hole
just one yeah
like why do I need all these mice
I don't know if I do well can you win
the level with one Mouse dying
are you allowed to do that so now
I want these mice it's a
it's a fall in line get up and get this
other thing that's right
which you will now successfully do yeah
oh oh I I killed one doctor we've lost
collateral damage it doesn't matter
we've lost another I've got all of the
mysterious uh gem things so isn't that
what matters
wait you have to kill that other Mouse I
think
okay
and that counts as a completion does it
did we really win here
but at what cost at what cost
at what cost possible that sounds like
yeah that sounds like my science class
from high school
passable all right adequate we'll take
it rat toys behave exactly like mice let
us let them touch the Miss let us
continue our experiments in this way
where we obtain all blue stuff
regardless of mice casualties okay
yeah that seems like a good uh that's
how I want to play that's a scientific
method
we're gonna use here
smash
probably shouldn't have done that well
go away television I get it
like a fan
fan Vision it's just there
go away
I won't all right well this one I think
that seems like a reasonable thing to do
and you can trap him in there if you
place it there now yeah but what about
this Square
how does this Square allow the mice to
escape from here because it's only two
things wide okay
yes problem I'm having I do seize a
square
so they can fall
right like I could put that here
that's fine
and but then they fall into that hole
you think you might so they can fall
they can do the entire second piece on
their own
so maybe you need both blocks for the
first puzzle
but of course you'll never get the
second gem there
no Gems by any means necessary this is
our scientific method oh you have two
blocks that's why
there's two no I think that's just block
number two
no you're right Mary
as your assistant
I must I don't know who's the assistant
here you got you got that one encourage
you nailed it
zero casualties you know that that's one
that the the board will be happy that's
an Optimum experimentation but we can't
always expect such Fine Results perfect
or passable we don't care which one
baby I'm passable
now look at these little dweebs they're
just gonna oh they can all right oh wow
wow one rat toy just threshes its way
through all the mice they really did eat
them that was vicious it was aggressive
so you have two of those
yeah okay I think that
where's the cheese
it's gonna be down here on this thing it
doesn't look like there's no cheese
there
explain
wow cheese on every level not every
level has cheese
I love will just have blue stuff
all right so this is a this is a good
place for one is it
they can fall three
I think I might even be able to juice a
rattoid
now they're gonna go they're going to go
bam backwards on the stream so they're
going to go to the right
uh and now I just want to lock one of
the rats and you have no no bangs
oh but now the friggin rattoid is
trapped down there
maybe we'll get lucky oh wait no I
wanted the ball you've also lost a blue
crystal because they're not gonna get
that blue crystal
and so now it's just a matter of how
many get eaten by this right oh no
oh no all of them oh the horror
oh the humanity
when will we learn
hubris
like if I put this it falls immediately
so it's not good for blocking it should
just be for crushing you gotta crush
them good
these two come back and this is like my
crush Zone because that was a good
that's the way to get that gem right
yeah and I can Crush one
maybe you can Crush that I want to be
able to crush two with one placement no
Crush that one
plowing and then
this other one is a real it's a real
problem
I believe we have chat help
so now if you guys
think you're so freaking smart
please and they do please by all means
assist us
this is the same thing I did last time
all right
I feel like maybe one of them will
escape the nefarious clutches of the
rattoid yeah
count it
accessible possible
team passable
get that trending sometimes misconstrued
with Team possible but that's not what
we are no no just we make
possible possible
oh this is gonna let them let them go
because I need the bams do it
go get your bam that's one bam so if you
erase that line under the square the
square will fall
so I was just gonna throw that under
that ratoyed
now eat it
it's important for scientists to
maintain a professional demeanor
on doing science
boom that
pleased with the amount of murder two
more bams
I feel like if I just bomb these two
once they come back over the side okay
how far will they fall
I think that's something to be
all you guys get down there
and then one more bomb to this one all
right oh
oh
we're not gonna allow freaking idiot hey
that was her rat's fault not you turn
around right
now let's do go in the right direction
that it was even worse that was worse
want them do you want them they all have
to look to the right and they're not
going to so you're going to have rat
casualties
oh my goodness yeah I can avoid you are
determined listen I don't know man
I just
no get it oh I gotta you know what I
gotta do what do something calmly wait
hold on
why don't we calmly discuss this
nope that doesn't work
foreign
can you go forward in time
don't be ridiculous Mary I don't know
anything about some things are Beyond
why don't you just erase the top block
the top right block okay okay that's one
no yeah no that one that's
and then when they're down there
not this one yeah they should survive
there we go as your assistant I would
recommend I don't know you took the lead
on that one
co-science what is a co-science
operation that's really what science is
it's about a collaborative effort
between two Geniuses to murder mice
between two stunning intellects
just
evil laugh
between two stunning intellects to
create the most perfect mouth science
ever created by man
that was not my best work
how about can we get some witch on uh I
feel like yeah you go for we should we
should expand our evil laugh repertoire
kill
those rat mice yeah
I killed them use their ghost to inspire
you
oh
it's it's uh
it's exciting whoever said it's like a
maniac murder doesn't feel good
never murdered anyone
I'm just gonna put it out there probably
it was not a murderer never said that
never murdered anyone so we do get a
bomb uh-huh
so we should consider
they're not high enough to obtain the
bomb or the blue ice
I just thought it'd work well I'll let
you know
but that's okay uh oh
well that's quitter talk
how are they going to get up there
because if all right one of these yep
that's good
that's good boom
then we can if you
this is gonna be some timing on your end
timing
I was just gonna say yeah once they get
the blue ice
I'm just gonna call it that from now on
sure
um if you erase the block that will fall
and possibly crush the rats
let's go to the videotape nope nope
you could probably save a few
do it
you save that one
I'm a genius
all right no that Mouse is gonna die if
you don't do something like right now
calmly
I wish save that Mouse
I have a bomb so I should have bombed
this
and then I can like put this down here
this rat will
put this down here but then
that was that was really bad I was I've
seen a lot of Science and that's one of
the worst science I've ever seen oh he's
turning around do something stop him
stop him he's gonna die to his mousy
death I was devastating all right so I
earned a trophy for that so clearly I'm
doing something right this would be good
to like break the fall so if I can get
one rat you need him to fall to the
right I I suppose you could you could
split them up
right time
so what if I release the rats
when
those things are right in the right
position okay
now
now is the time
go back in time and do it right that was
just a mental error I'm upset yeah
everyone's upset
all of our interns in the lab are
distraught
all right
hey
no
this is going to create
oh right the other ones that's fine as
long as we have one he's gonna turn
around and die no no
you're not calmly doing anything
as long as we have one Mouse live that's
that's gonna be okay with the board of
directors
so let me
let me ask my boss
yeah we got to go ahead
yeah it's oh what it jumped up into
there jump where did it jump it jumped
into where I placed the piece during uh
all right it was it was all very bad
this is the worst science ever
alright so
well that that solution was working
we're gonna go with that one
worst science ever though it seems
excessive
at least I'm gonna get two I got two a
lot I feel good without trade
uh-oh okay remember what I said we're
gonna get to
black guy die
oh you can make the ratoids kill
themselves if you erase that block
erase that box get out of here then
those die see you later dweebs
where was the TV explaining that all
right so now we have to explain to
yourself
that's gonna be a that this place here
will allow
placed here right we'll get us those two
eyes and they won't die yeah
oh we're on to something here oh
now
brain now we put this one
here right and then when the first Mouse
when there's a yep and then erase that
block when their last Mouse
is turning around
before he turns around
so race it now just need one to turn
around yeah
oh yeah yeah
a plus oh my goodness
so genius
what what is this we got a gelatin
oh my God I was right right I mean it's
it's very clear from the visual design
eh jelly brick soft things roads fall
and prevents them from dying When
jumping from more than three units
jelly break
gross I've invented jelly breaks or
appetizing
a jello's good
yes I are you a joke I love Jello and
not only for science
but but also for consumption so if you
just lay that brick down
then they won't die
yep it's right here right there we think
this is just the training for jelly I
assume
it's funny it's like
oh look at them they love it I assume
it's
how are they getting
hold on hold the phone okay how are we
gonna oh okay we're gonna have to blow
that guy
and they get the bottom we blow the
other one right
by exit go mousy men go I like the
effect when they don't be alarmed and
they jump on the gel
the jiggle
the jello jigglers the jelly jiggle
the TV tells us we're perfect Mary
isn't that wonderful
science has proven
it can be our science portraits
what is going on here
where are they going to be up so high
that they're going to fall all right
another puzzle for the scientists
what happens when you blow this one
comes down
it seems I liked that experiment Chris
thank you I like what you're doing and
they can
if they fall onto
this goo it's so goo
SE jelly here but then they're not going
to get that extra
um
how do they even get up there what's
your plan Stan
you mind if I call you Stan no that's
fine I'm uh open to
scientific nickname
nickname we've done it
you saved all the rats but only one of
the blue ices
good acceptable unacceptable don't say
good it did say good
I don't understand
it's a game it's weird
I mean
when you put a block there it makes me
want to explode it immediately
like this yeah it's just it makes me
want to do any reason to not explode
this block
because like you get stairs now here's
my thought
if you don't do it go back in time
please use your science Powers if you
build stairs
uh do we have the ability to build
stairs to go up there then one Mouse
will fall and get that bomb and ice
if you could do that if you have the
power
seems like it would be a real waste of
resources
yeah it doesn't because
I don't think we can I think that the
stairs in order to get those mice up
there we need to have this piece in play
but can I take over here's what we do
okay oh yeah you can take over no you do
it you have an idea here's my idea
execute your idea if it's flawed at all
as I predict I will take over okay and
win first step just let these guys have
a little run go on grab this thing fair
enough we don't have to block anything
we'll casually place a block now calmly
gonna now I think it's time to calmly
blow this upload go
you're gonna have to okay
the block goes so we could use either of
these blocks we could use this one
or we could use this one okay so the
question is which one do we want over
here
and later in time you mean oh you went
back in time again
question is which one do we want over
here because
like we need the presumably the jelly
one the gel will will will save all and
you might as well place that
gel seems like it has to be here yeah
they're gonna fall from there yes but
if one if you explode it when the last
Mouse is on it he'll get the he'll get
the bomb
and the in the blue and the blue eyes
explode
fuels no because I can't explode until I
do get a bomb I have no extra spload you
have no splod
GE it's loadless
I feel like you know what we don't I
mean you need that extra because like we
could do this right that would block
them and it would cut they would come
back
and pick up that last gem but then how
do they get the bomb
in order to remove that barrier that we
created so that they could get the gym
great
so I feel like there's some first off
one of these we still need to reserve to
finish the stairwell
this one
is I feel like it's safe in the confines
of the gel Zone
it's so
so
because yeah we got the barrier right go
right there okay that was what we were
thinking about before but it won't get
the bomb we won't get the bomb and then
this barrier will remain a barrier
forever more
that is so barrier
same deal with this
they won't
if only we could force them to turn
around
through some kind of Inception
well you're going straight to Inception
that's like that's like all right what
if we put it down here
long fall go on then
all on it
but then see they still don't get the
bomb because they could no they can't
climb I'll take it through that that's
crazy it's crazy top it's Madness no
I do have chat
I'm gonna read the chat all right I
think people are telling me I should
read Chad well you had said before that
you wanted to take a whack at it do you
want to grab this thing and try moving
stuff around you got it somebody's
saying and I don't think they're right
she needs to read my marriage proposal
I'm not going to take those seriously no
honestly
without PRI like some kind of scientific
proof
you're gonna follow through yeah we need
a scientific proof also not sending them
to my PSN account it's not lazy it's not
how they're going to be
what you want me to do
the chat is that you're probably going
to say something like put the block
there and that's awful let's just watch
this happen because I don't know what
that means
just watch this happen also Andy please
stop sending invitations
thank you
do you start the experiment with any
bombs
you do don't you
yes with the one that we use to make the
uh the stair thing fall down which is I
believe the proper decision I believe
that's necessary because otherwise
remember we decided we couldn't make the
stairwell
given these pieces
because this doesn't allow the one step
and the only other piece we could use it
would be this
does allow the one step
so maybe
that yes Mary yay that's I think this is
it so wait
except I think we might kill a mouse
that's okay all right so we're gonna let
we're gonna let some mice so drop off
the ledge that's right get the ball need
Mouse that's right
and then you and let the kill the middle
Mouse probably hey wait can't you stop
them with a block or no because what's
the point of the block at this point
there's no point for the block although
you can only explode one thing yes so I
suppose now I can explode too once my
the other mouse gets that bomb oh well
then yeah stop them with that block let
one pass stop the other two with a block
and then destroy both blocks
that's that's the humane way to do it
yeah
yeah zero mice casualties give a shot do
they have a space of two mice in between
them I don't think so no because this I
think this will kill a mouse
because like if he's already begun his
jumping animation
listen
you can't make a mouse omelet without
breaking a few mice
I believe that's
that's accurate that is science all
right so now that that Mouse has gone
over right we're gonna kill this one
Mouse right sorry buddy oh wait I forgot
to put the jelly thing down
you forgot about the goo
SE what were we even doing okay putting
this down right we've got to put the goo
down correct
little did he know what did I make for a
science fair project that's a great
question
um
I totally did those I'm trying to think
what did we do because you knew what
everybody did right they made possible
science class everyone did the same
thing right they did the
um
volcano and they put dry ice in it or
yeah dry ice if you were like it was
like smoking you have some sort of
um like national funding for your
science project you buy dry ice
what you didn't have dry ice at home no
we did not all of us grew up on a rat
farm that used dry ice to preserve their
rats I come from a very high-end family
where we uh I never had dry ice
um okay I know one science experiment we
did was
um I actually went to a science
Elementary School where we like did more
science experiments than anything else
we did all sorts of weird stuff yeah we
built
um we built buildings out of
um sugar cubes and put them on Jello and
then simulated uh earthquakes to see
what structures held up fast
against
earthquake what did you learn what did
you learn from your findings why
bottom buildings make the Rock and World
Go Round because they stood up the best
under your shaking Jello and then we got
to eat the jello at the end of the day
that is my kind of science that was a
really good mom hanging up there
um
I don't know if we had a science fair
yeah
um what else did I do I did I do feel
like I did did some baking soda
experiments baking soda experiments are
like natural I'm trying to think what
else we did um we did one where we had
common household items and we had to see
how long we could make one Ice Cube not
melt so it was about building insulation
I
got a water bottle and I insulated it
with
styrofoam and believe it or not I think
I used scarf like an old scarf and cut
it up because the same material that
keeps you warm also insulates cold
um and then you we had a timer to see
how long our ice cubes would
would make it
um
I think I did okay do the egg drop
oh yeah I remember that like to see how
you could protect the
if you did that as well
I haven't been paying attention to the
experiment I know so um allow me to help
you
all of your not paying attention
attitude
the word is
listen I think in all great
experiments
of which this certainly is right right
yeah there's gonna be one naysayer
which is you sakitume
he was ruining my chill listen
I'm pretty sure I just solved this whole
thing without you go on
where's the blue ice
let's see him get all the blue ice
you're gonna see it
just wait exploded something aren't you
no I am calmly calmly
get it
that was pretty good oh yeah pretty good
I don't think the TV is going to say
pretty good B minus I think if we stay
here you know why all it says perfect oh
attitude perfect can affect science and
yours is a seed triumphant so I'm gonna
average it out a good scientist takes
pride in the accomplishments of science
that the scientist does for science
you did nothing you're awesome
foreign
Chris Waters what
always takes the best people down a peg
like myself
just because I was Raising myself up a
few pegs doesn't mean I was taking you
down a peg I want a science too all
right you can do the next one
nope that's not what I meant to do you
never let me science anymore come on do
this one
you already did it no I didn't
you just did it badly yeah no I did it
good
Lee ish here you go boom I don't know
the controls
X is to do stuff X is like grab in place
if you want to blow stuff up you press
triangle
uh circle is back so I only have to
disengage a move I only have this guy
this is my only guy I have two of them
oh I do have two of them
so naturally it probably wants you to
put it
in this Google right here that certainly
seems Square shaped
I
I yeah if you don't you
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
science
this is what we call wobble science it's
uh
a shoot of main thrust science but
wobble science is
definitely yup see Mary uh got her PhD
in wobble science some may not know that
some may think that wobble science you
as an online degree is not an accredited
University but not Mary you don't know
anything about science
all right so let's do this again
my thought is
you start with zero bombs and the only
bomb that you can acquire is that first
we break up the mice okay so you start
the mice by pressing Square okay how do
I pause the game casually that's a
touchpad
yeah
you gotta do it anyway sometimes in
science you got to do things you're not
too Keen about
well so my thought is let's run through
this experiment
my thought is make one Mouse hit the
edge and turn back and then destroy that
square
I like it I like it a lot Mary okay
that's what I'm gonna do
okay
I'm testing yeah this is an experiment
this is all nested experiments within
experiments there's a lot okay
okay
all right so I believe
how do I bomb
triangle
so I believe this is what I want to do
yeah I think so
I think you're in Biz and is
okay
and then
I want to explode
that
let's see it
and then oh I think this is glorious
success how do I speed it up old Square
I'm not going to because I really want
to enjoy it but I just wanted to know
how
you're just gonna savor it look at him
eat some of that Jello where's the eat
button
there's they eat Autumn they don't
actually eat they just Huff look at
these
yeah see it's hard to have a humble
attitude when you're doing perfect
science perfect science
I feel like a real science baller I'm
such a science baller yeah which was the
the term we coined for perfect science
perfect science is done by science
Ballers what oh my goodness it's long
ish science Ballas fallen for science
all right so now I'm allowed to look
around
although I would have to say it's
incredibly Limited
stop looking around there's not a lot to
look at all right so first things first
these mises are gonna die
or are they or I have bombs yep so let's
consider the option
of destroying this
you got to how else are your mice going
to get to the rest of the parts in the
place
I wanted to do it
with both of them over there because
then they wouldn't be in my way
I want to go back in time they're always
in your way they're just going to fall
down there anyways oh
listen rattoids I didn't think this
through bounce on Jello no I think
that's what you have to do I think
you're doing fine
now you could use your second bomb
to crush to crush
like butt like how they're not in the
right spot well not with the block with
the other bomb that you have I can crush
them with a
I need to go back in time
pause it right now
Square oh never mind
so there is if you bomb that t-square
both of those lines go plow I like your
thinking about involves smashing rats
and it involves the animals I like that
word yeah so I'm gonna go with your
recommendation
of completed
all right here we go
science wait for it in three
two smash
that was not a very scientific countdown
it's very important in science but
you do this is that the end well it's
not because if they will continue to go
to the right and they'll get the cheese
before they'll get the blue guy so I'm
gonna put up a block and force them to
go to the left
so I'll put that there and then I will
make them go with what Square yep go
and that'll speed up time
minions and then
I'll blow the crap out of this kaplawy
and then I'll speed up time oh yeah
perfect 100 success rate
science
that's a good science pose
can we get a full screen science pose
please we'll do it at the end probably
right
oh this is the end
I think that time flies when you're
science ending it on perfect science
execution is uh really the only way we
could do this here on random I can't
believe that I scienced so good you were
a great scientist Mary what never
doubted it out of a score would you give
yourself me yeah I gotta self-evaluate
yeah well I think I think that's normal
for scientists to do yeah yeah I would
rate myself
like a like a Buckminster Fuller
yeah
yeah who is the people who killed
themselves
um studying
radiation and then they got poisoned
Marie Curie and Louis Pasteur I am Marie
Curie
I'm Mary Curry
Marie Marie Curie Mary Curie Mary Curry
all right um counter folks thanks for
watching I think we have a live stream
later today for
Space Engineers Engineers I think Rob's
going to build more space wieners yep
that's probably accurate and then uh so
science about 24 hours from now we'll be
playing some destiny destiny destiny
destiny I will be back tomorrow with
with You Chris well Destiny yeah all
right uh ready for the science pose
yes three two one side pose